today's question comes from jordan
in california she visits daveramsey.com
to ask i am wondering
what the better option is when on baby
step two or three
buying something cheap and that's going
to need to be replaced quickly
or making room in the budget for a
higher quality item
that will last last a long time
in baby step two two or three you won't
be buying anything
that's what i was thinking but if you're
like none of the above
if your car though has to be replaced
like it
dies on you and you're like okay i need
a new car you go cheap cheap cheap
uh making sure it's reliable and you're
not having to go to the mechanic
every other day yeah this is like three
thousand dollars cheap yeah you want
like 30 000 sheep
right well just some people get confused
about what that means
that's fair all relative all relative um
you get a freaking hoopty when you're in
baby step two or three
and you don't upgrade anything you only
do
emergency spending it's the only
spending you do
because it's an emergency to get out of
debt you are in gazelle intensity mode
that's exactly right so um
here's the thing you can wander
into debt most people do
it's normal in our culture to be in debt
everyone teaches you to be in debt
all the people that want you to buy crap
from them tell you to be in debt
everybody is talking about being in debt
and everybody's broke
the only people that talk about getting
out of debt are those people that are
wealthy
and that's how they got wealthy i mean
you talk to wealthy people this is what
you're going to find out
and and so what is required here
you are you are going against
the entire set of
cultural influences not only in your
life but in all of our lives
and so the idea to get out of debt and
stay out of debt
requires tremendous emotional
energy you gotta
and you can't just kind of go well i
can't think and then do i buy something
cheaper
no you have to get fired up
and wired up i mean because you're going
against
everybody everybody's going to think
you're
crazy except wealthy people
i mean you and so you have to exert this
extreme
amount of energy to break through all
these
barriers in your psyche that's right
well you said it earlier you can wander
your way in like most people do but you
can't
wander your way out like there has to be
a level of intensity
there has to be a level of like you're
going against the grain and it's going
to feel uncomfortable
change is hard it's not always fun but
as you start making that progress and
you start saying things like oh yeah
yeah i got no we're not buying anything
like nothing all our extra money is
going towards this debt
not only do you get out of debt faster
and you advance in so many ways
financially and emotionally spiritually
all of that because you just have no
payments you don't owe anyone
anything but on top of that something
changes within you that level of
sacrifice
really does it's this iron sharpening
iron and the and the process of it all
refines you and i think what ends up
happening is you start to realize okay
all this stuff
that probably put me in debt in the
first place wow it really doesn't matter
like when i sacrifice stuff and i start
selling things off
like suddenly even your your value
system starts to change in our in our
culture
in your life that goes against the
culture the point of gazelle intensity
is is gazelle's running from a cheetah
for his life you have to run
for your life
you cannot just act like this is an
academic
intellectual exercise you're
carving new grooves in your brain
and the only way you do that is with
when people look at you and go you're so
extreme
then you're right on track because those
are stupid broke people that are saying
that
i think i don't think i could do it
you're daring that's
you dadgum right you couldn't cause i'm
a winner and you're a loser i mean these
things have to go through your head
if broke people are making fun of your
financial plan you're right on track
but if they're not making fun of you
you're not doing it right
because you need to go to scorched earth
because you're setting your whole
psyche your relationships to stuff
your relationship with your spouse
everything's in a whole new
zone and you're basically taking an
emotional
bulldozer and digging a new ditch in
your life
and this is not like i just think i'll
have a little ditch here now you're
digging a hole you're getting out of
this
mess you're changing and you
you cannot half but do this stuff and so
you can't
go on vacation when you're in baby step
two
that's freaking lame-o you can't be
going out to eat when you're in baby
step two
that's freaking lame-o you're getting
out of debt like your hair is on fire
like your children's lives depend on it
because they do you're changing your
family tree
and you don't do that without this this
thing happening inside of you and that's
when people change their lives
when they finally say i've had it the
level of intensity
is so so crucial in the process yeah and
it's going to lead you
to deeper sacrifice and that frees up
the math
goofing around with the intensity will
lead you to
watered-down wissified levels of
sacrifice which screws up the math
and you stay in debt longer and you have
a higher probability of never making it
out
because you run out of steam and
possibly going back in yeah and you just
give up and you go i'm gonna go be
normal screw it yeah screw it i'm gonna
be broke like everybody else and look
like i'm not
and i'm just gonna go buy crap i can't
afford money that i don't have to
impress people i don't even like and i'm
gonna go back to those old ways and
you just gotta you know you have to
reach a point that you go
no no
and so picking on jordan a little bit
the point is
when you're in that mindset you don't
even ask the question that you asked
jordan
it wouldn't have even come up unless
it's an emergency expenditure like a car
went could put like you talked about
rachel
yep yep you don't ask a question of what
level of vacation can i go on
you don't deserve a vacation you're
freaking broken in debt
don't tell me you're entitled to squat
you're not
when i was broke and rachel's a baby
and the electricity gets cut off i can't
come in and go
you know i work so hard i think we need
to go on a vacation
no we need to turn the dadgum lights
back on we have a baby in the house
you can't you know your whining is
unbelievable
and you it happens inside of all of our
heads it happened with us i mean
we you know we've been fighting against
bankruptcy for two and a half years we
hit bottom we're bankrupt we got
zero it would have been real easy to
justify well we've been through this
horrible time and
we just really need to rest and you know
you can't do that
what an option because we've freaking
been on the street
and i wonder what the the level of
even from 30 years ago to now 35 years
ago to now
the amount of comfort we have in our
lives today
from the accessibility of just
information getting what we want when we
want it
you know amazon anything to be at your
doorstep even that day like there's a
level of comfort we live
oh we're spoiled rotten yep you can pick
up a little square thing and touch
buttons and stuff shows up on your
doorstep to be
uncomfortable right now in life is very
scary and uncomfortable
but you have to be uncomfortable in this
process if you continue to just be
comfortable you're not going to get the
progress
but that comfortability is is sweeps all
of us
it's it's in all of us we're we're
spoiled
rotten we really are i mean when you can
pick up that little square thing
and touch three buttons this stuff shows
up on your front porch
and you can touch three buttons and get
the answer to any one button and get the
answer to almost any question
you can't even have a good argument
anymore you know because the answer is
right there
you know and so you know you know when's
early voting in well it's right there
you just google it i mean we were
laughing the other day anthony and i
like all the questions people ask us
here on the radio they don't need to ask
they could just google it google it you
know and so
but you know if if it's the dirty little
secret of the dave ramsey show there's
nothing here that you didn't already
know
or you could just watch one of our nine
million hours of youtube right for free
so uh uh you know that kind of stuff and
the dirty little secret is that it's all
right there
we're spoiled rotten though yeah and it
makes us feel like we're entitled
to pleasure we're entitled to luxury yep
that's it
and we are not when you're broke you're
not entitled
your brain may say it's entitled but
your brain's being a baby child